Đây đây, em đang làm nó đang hơi không kiểm soát được ạ
Thì đề tài của em là em sẽ cố gắng sử dụng GAN trong
Em có, em viết tiếng Anh, quên chưa đổi lại
Thì em dùng GAN để tấn công SQL
bài toán thì là hiện tại là dữ liệu thì sẽ hầu hết sẽ là các dữ liệu của người dùng rất
bình thường đôi lúc mới có dữ liệu tấn công thì tỷ lệ sẽ rơi khoảng từ 100 trên 1 thì tới 1.000
trên 1 thì theo phương pháp bình thường thì mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là lọc dữ liệu rồi chuyển nó thành
vector có thể dùng MOT để kiểu định dạng lại thì lúc này mình sẽ dùng GAN bởi vì GAN nó có thể
còn cái thằng kia nó chỉ đơn giản nội sinh nghĩa là mình đưa cho nó cái gì thì nó cũng chỉ thay đổi các string
nó chỉ học nội sinh thôi nhưng nó không có khả năng sinh ra những cái dữ liệu mới để mình có thể học tiếp
em mới đề xuất ra thì đây là mô hình của em ạ
thì là đầu tiên là em sẽ lấy dữ liệu là lấy dữ liệu trên Kaggle và một số cái Datap
lấy thêm dữ liệu của các cái CVE, nghĩa là người ta ghi nhận những cái tấn công
dữ liệu thì em lấy thì em cũng mới chỉ lấy khoảng 30.000
bởi vì là dữ liệu tấn công thực tế
thì khi mà em làm thì em thấy là hầu hết là nó chỉ là noise
nghĩa là nó chỉ có khả năng tấn công
lúc mà em gõ thật thì khả năng tấn công thực tế của nó là không có
Nó khá là ít. Này em mới nhận ra.
Tiếp theo trong mô hình nó sẽ có 2 thành phần.
Đầu tiên là thành phần Generate và thành phần Qua lịa và thành phần Quy tích.
Thì em có thêm vào là
Trong này là sẽ có thêm một
Thì trong này em sẽ có thêm cái mutation
Nghĩa là em sẽ cho nó biết định nghĩa về các
Cho cả hai thằng
Cái
Vậy là gây nhiễu nữa
Vâng
Không em cái này là em cũng mới tìm hiểu
Thì em đang hiểu là em sẽ cho nó biết là
bây giờ SQL Injection thì nó sẽ phải có những điều kiện tối thiểu là gì
em cho cả 2 thằng nó học luôn
còn nếu mà làm theo kiểu bình thường thì nó đang hơi loạn
sau khi mà critic thành công xong
em sẽ có thêm 1 lớp để check nữa
thì nó sẽ gồm 3 cái
đầu tiên kiểm tra xem có phải là SQL không
là cái lờ 1
tiếp theo sẽ kiểm tra xem khả năng Injection của nó
nghĩa là xem thực tế nó có khả năng tấn công không
Hiện tại là em mới chỉ cho quét qua bộ thư viện open source ở trên mạng
Còn cái số 3 là em sẽ quét xem là độ đa dạng
xem là nó có thật sự đa dạng, nó có thật sự hơn được
thay thế được SMODE không ạ
thì trong tương lai thì em sẽ thay thế thằng L2
bằng cách là em cho tấn công thực tế trên các tương lửa thông dụng
Và cái cuối cùng là các cái thước đo để xem là mô hình của em đạt những giá trị nào
Thì em cũng vận
Thì đây là kết quả
Thì nếu như mà tỷ lệ mà rất rất cân bằng như kiểu 500 trên 1 ạ
Cái cuộc ngoài cùng ạ
Thì là nó thì cái mô hình gan nó sẽ hơn được cái phương pháp cơ bản là 42%
Nhưng mà càng lên cao thì nếu mà tỷ lệ càng thấp
Thì thằng Smoth nó sẽ thắng được thằng Gan
Thì tỷ lệ đây em chọn là 100 trên 1
Em cho rằng tỷ lệ mất cân bằng đủ để mình có thể dùng phương pháp Gan
Thì đây thì hình bên phải
Thì là em cũng thử là chia ra là 4 trường hợp
Nghĩa là trong tấn công SQL sẽ có 4 trường hợp
Thì 2 trường hợp đầu tiên là Boolean và Error
Thì là cái này là dựa trên phản hồi của máy chủ
Nghĩa là nó không thực sự tấn công
Nó sẽ đợi xem phản hồi máy chủ là gì
Và từ đó họ sẽ
Mường tượng xem là hệ thống của
Mô hình là như nào
Thì nên là 2 cái đầu là nó sẽ không có
Không có đặc biệt
Bởi vì nó chỉ đơn giản là tấn công những cái
Mà mình đã biết rồi ạ
Nhưng mà 2 cái cuối cùng là sẽ